do you believe Allah is a biological
being I don't I don't know I can't even
I don't know what kind you don't know if
Allah is a biological being see I don't
know so there's none like unto him are
you a biological being I am a biological
being yes okay there's none like unto
him is Allah a biological being well if
there's none like unto him and I no one
seen him I haven't seen him how am I
supposed to describe him we are at the
point where Muslims don't know if Allah
is a b logical being or not this is
interesting I I really have to admit
this I did not expect this type of
Direction in the live stream this is
amazing we don't even know if Allah is a
biological being or not this is amazing
so one second go ahead so if I said to
you for example um right so can you
describe your God my God is Spirit he is
immaterial he is not physical um he is
Everlasting he's Eternal without
beginning Without End he has no form no
physical form or visible form that we
can see him unless he appears visibly so
would you say scientifically he's not
he's not basically he got Prov him by
science and he is not a physical he's
Beyond science like you can you can you
can prove you can point to him through
science like science points to him right
the evidence of his existence but you
can't put God in a test tube for example
like science is the study of physical
the physical world he is beyond the phys
so one second so then how do you know
he's like this have you seen him he
revealed this to us no have you seen him
physically of course not right so then
how can you say that he's not physically
he's not biolog because he created the
physical he created the material world
so therefore he himself will have to be
outside of material is it possible that
Allah is a physical being that is also
within time is it possible that Allah is
a physical being that is in time H let
me think about this one
that's a deep question bro that's a very
deep question so it's Allah a physical
being right that's going through time
now right the philosopher in me would
like to say that how do we know that we
are actually physical beings are we not
just like a brain in a jar that have
created this reality and therefore we're
actually a reality within a reality
right so yeah so I don't I don't know
bro I'll be honest with you God Alone
knows fair enough so you don't know you
don't know I don't I don't think that
this is that complicated but but this is
the it's The Logical problem of I'll say
that the lpt it's The Logical problem of
Ted because um your God is so go Allah
is so unknown to you like like he's so
unknown to you how do you even know that
you're even worshiping him how do you
even know that you're even worshiping
him the right way because we've got the
sunah but how do you know that that's
his son how do you really know that
because bro he literally told the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that this is the way to but how
do you know that you see like now you
have to because you don't know you don't
know the most basic thing about about
your God so how do you even know that he
even revealed himself when he hasn't
revealed nothing to you is revealed the
Quran bro how do you know that because
it's literally the word of God bro know
that so I could I could I could turn the
exact same question on you and say how
do you not the Bible
I I will be able to give you I will be
able to give you a basis for why I say
the Bible is the word of God I can give
you the answer to that I can I can tell
you what my God told me about himself
that he's not physical he's spiritual
and eternal outside of time matter and
space because he's the creator of it so
he's not limited to space time and
matter he's not a physical being he's an
immaterial being beyond the physical
right I can tell you this because that's
what he revealed how do I know that he
revealed it because he actually spoke in
history spoke the end from the beginning
and SE we can see that stuff comes to
pass for what he said like the
crucifixion of the Messiah the the
destruction of of of Jerusalem and and
the city uh Cyrus a few hundred years
before he's born Isaiah mentions him and
Cyrus comes and saves Israel from
Babylon I can show you all of these
things to show you proof that God really
spoke in history and revealed himself to
mankind what do you have okay I'll tell
you what we have so I looked at the best
description of Allah in the Quran and he
says
which it says say he is Allah the one
and the only how do you know he's saying
that how do you know he's revealing that
one second second the Eternal the
absolute how do you know he is okay I'll
tell you how I know essentially in the
Quran right there's a continuity right
of the stories of M of Isa of IM Iman of
all these other Prophet stories that
existed already one second right but
then certain details were revealed that
were not revealed to the Jews oh so it's
contradicting the actual stories of the
prophets not a continuation got it it's
not none whatsoever how is it
contradicting show me one contradiction
how many signs were did did God send on
Egypt how many signs did God send on
Egypt
um right so I'll have to Google this
because I I got you the answer is 10 but
the Quran says nine okay you want to
know what sign it left out go on it left
out the Passover you know what the
Passover is yeah so essentially when the
Jews were told to uh get the
Lambs yes the Quran leaves that out and
only mentions nine signs contradicting
what the story of uh the story of the
prophets the the most one of the most
important stories so the nine signs
right so the the Passover you're saying
is missed out from the Quran yeah right
okay so why do you think the Passover
would be missed out from the ground oh
man I'm glad you asked the reason why is
because the p lamb is a foreshadowing of
the Messiah who is the Lamb of God who
takes away the sins of the world just
like the Passover Lamb the lamb is
slaughtered and its blood covers the
doorpost and so therefore God's Wrath
passes over whoever is covered by the
blood of the Lamb same way Jesus who is
the Lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world shed his blood and whoever
is covered by the blood of the Messiah
God's Wrath passes over and whoever is
not covered by the blood of the Messiah
they under condemnation that's why the
Quran left that out amazing huh one
second so so is that an assumption
or it's biblical prophecy it's literally
the biblical thread that you have so
what you literally said there right was
essentially your words no that's that's
what the that's what the Bible says the
Bible says what the Passover Lamb is and
then the Bible also calls Jesus the lamb
the Lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world who sheds his blood blood
for the New Covenant that's for the
Forgiveness of sins the Bible literally
says that I'm literally quoting you
Bible if you want verses I can get you
so this is the thing though this is what
I mean so this is what Christians tend
to do so when you find similar words you
attribute them and you create your own
meaning for it and this is what the
Quran says essentially that they distort
words with their tongues what what did I
distort what what did I dist basically
you said so what you've done there you
created this uh what's they called the
the similitude or the comparison between
them using the Lamb's blood right to
paint their do so the wrath of God
wouldn't come upon them right and then
saying that that somehow signified just
because Jesus was called the lamb or
innocent lamb or whatever right he's
called the Lamb of God who takes away
the sin of the world whose blood is shed
for the Forgiveness of sins that's
that's what but he's also called The
Shepherd right yes right so then what if
you were to take a total different
meaning out of that well well another
well I can I can give you that answer
the fact that Jesus is called the
shepherd also points back to God himself
who is The Shepherd of Israel and who
brings the Believers and guides the
Believers into salvation into the and
and into uh into his covering it calls
look literally this is this is a song
right well how do the psalm go Psalm 23
I think it is the Lord is my shepherd I
shall not want like I don't need
anything he guides me and he leads me to
the uh among the pastors this is all a a
foreshadowing of Jesus and where Jesus
is always calling back to the Old
Testament saying this is about me I'm
this that Shepherd so Jesus was pointing
out his coming in the Old Testament but
Jesus if you pay if you he does if you
pay attention to what Jesus says
what the the the the the Parables that
he gives what he says about himself he's
always pointing back to the Old
Testament so all because all of this
stuff is linked all of this stuff is
linked bro it's not me just saying this
Jesus even Jesus literally says this he
says uh in Luke 24:44 he says this is
what I told you right when I was still
among you that all that's been written
about me in the law of Moses in the
Psalms and the prophets must be
fulfilled then it says in verse 45 he
opened their minds to understand the
scriptures so he Jesus himself points
back to the Old Testament about himself
about his coming about his identity
about who he is brilliant so he does so
the point the point of all this bro is
that your Quran is out of touch with all
of this and it contradicts
what the prophets taught and what Jesus
taught it's out of touch it doesn't this
is what I'm trying to say to you so the
Jews essentially believe that Jesus
wasn't the Son of God the Muslims
believe that he wasn't the Son of God
the only people that believe that he was
the son of the God was the Christians so
essentially who were the CHR wait who
are the Christians who are the
Christians that follow Jesus who are the
Christians that follow Jesus basically
all those that are not circumcised all
those wait wait wait wait wait you're
missing it you're missing it the people
who followed Jesus when he was here and
they believed in him and believed he was
the son of God who were they they were
the Jews and then Paul opened it up to
who so you see how the Jews believed
that Jesus the Messiah was the son of
God yeah but the Jews don't still
believe it do they yes they do matter of
fact it depends on what Jew you ask so
one second so this is this this is what
I understand you got believing Jews and
you got disbelieving Jews right so the
Jews essentially were the people that
were circumcised they fulfilled right
the Covenant that God made with Abraham
correct they were in the Covenant with
Abraham the Covenant of Abraham yes so
the Covenant of Abraham was they didn't
FF it they well initially the Covenant
that God made with Abraham and he told
uh Abraham to go to all his men folk and
make sure that they were all circumcised
including his sons right was that on the
day of judgment when they are raised God
will know the children of Abraham their
circumcision no that's not what the
Bible says at all that's not the purpose
of that but the Genesis yeah no not what
the Bible says Genesis 17 is what you're
talking about that's not what it says so
but but anyway what does that have to do
with with believing Jews who yeah
believe the Messiah as the Son of God
and then the disbelieving Jews who
reject him what's that got to do with
anything well see this is the thing I
don't believe that the believing Jews
believe that he was the son of God
really yeah I think that was a later
Edition because as I'm researching do
you have your Quran with you even I do
have the Quran with me yes okay do me
this favor brother go to chapter 61
ver14 chapter 61 Quan 61 I'm going to
show you how you're destroying Islam
when you say this that this is a later
addition that took over the the beliefs
by the real disbelieving people show I'm
going show you that you just you're
destroying your Quran all you who
believe be supporters of Allah as when
Jesus the son of Mary said to the
disciples who are my supporters for
Allah the disciples said said we are
supporters of Allah and a faction of the
children of Israel believed and a
faction disbelieved so we supported
those who believed against their enemy
and they became dominant beautiful so
the Believers of Jesus were helped by
Allah and spreading the message of Jesus
right yes and they became dominant over
the believers who tried to infiltrate
them stop them distort their message
whatever Allah helped the real Believers
of Jesus so so look at the wording again
may I read it again sure just in case
you missed it right so this is talking
about at the time of Jesus right nice
yes at the time of Jesus yeah correct so
yeah so if you look at when the um one
second let me bring this up again let me
read so so saying that after the time of
Jesus is when the disbelievers became
dominant over you know over the actual
Believers after the time of Jesus is
that what you're saying so yeah so
initially right we had the Christian
persecution right for the next 300 years
under the Romans when they were feeding
them to the Lions and the Tigers and
taking them to the coliseums and
torturing them right so there for
example were the Christians dominant no
they weren't they were being persecuted
and they were hiding their faith right
no they wasn't hiding their faith they
wasn't hiding their faith they get
punished for their faith well they were
hiding their faith until Constantine
came and he professed the religion and
that's when they all started coming out
of the Woodworks they wasn't hiding
their faith that's why there was a
persecution of the Christians they
wasn't hiding right but they weren't
openly practicing either they were
openly practicing that's why they were
persecuted cuz they were openly
practicing so they weren't the dominant
for then well they were they were
dominant against their disbelievers look
at what happened they took over they
took over and Rome became a Christian
Nation didn't it yeah that was only
because of Constantine right well that's
because the be by God's favor
Christianity spread into the Royal the
the the leadership and the rulership and
boom became a Christian Nation well it's
interesting that you said that because
Constantine apparently he was a
Unitarian and he believed him and
Gregory actually I don't care about
Constantine I don't care about
Constantine but I I want you to focus
here though so you're saying that it was
only during the time of Jesus and his
father followers that you know they were
dominant over the disbelievers who would
come against them but then after that
time then the disbelievers got the upper
hand and became dominant is that right
yeah I'll tell you why I believe that
right you don't you don't even have to
tell me why it's it's I'm even I'm
granting it all to you I'm just I'm
granting it to you I understand the
position right okay so he my logic out
so hear my logic so I think right
essentially that the Romans already had
this idea of God's and God is having
Sons dude that's that's that's fine all
of that is besides the point trust me
I'm showing you how your position
destroys Islam that's all I'm that's all
I'm solidifying okay it doesn't destroy
it bro okay I'm about to show you give a
foundation I'm about to show you I'm
about to show you how you just show that
Allah is either and I'm not I'm not
saying this in disrespect to you we're
having a conversation but this is the
conclusion either Allah is a liar
and did not and fail and failed to keep
his promise or he was too weak to keep
his promise to make the Christians
dominant I going show you why go to
chapter 3: 55 now we see that during the
time of Jesus different chapter yeah
yeah but the same same uh same thing is
saidan 3:55 yeah right so remember when
Allah said oh Jesus I will take you and
raise you up to myself I will deliver
you from those who disbelieve and
elevate your followers above the
disbelievers until the day of judgment
then to me you will all return and I
will settle all your disputes okay so
what's what's your point so we see here
it is again that Allah repeats it he's
he's recalling remember when I said this
and you know and supported your
Believers and he says how long will they
remain dominant will the Believers of
Jesus those who follow Jesus how long
will they remain dominant over the
disbelievers until the day of judgment
until the day of judgment but see you're
saying that they were only dominant for
the time of Jesus but then after that
the disbelievers overcame them and
became dominant but this says that they
will remain dominant until the day of
Resurrection so either Allah lied or he
failed or both or you misunderstood it
and let me explain how okay right so
remember when Allah said to Jesus so
he's saying to he's talking to Jesus all
right so this is the context this is the
time so this has happened in a specific
time frame so he says to Jesus I will
take you and I will raise you up to
myself I will deliver you from those who
disbelieve so he's delivering them he's
saving them he's pulling away Jesus from
those people who are disbelieving him at
that specific moment in time and elevate
your followers above the disbelievers so
who were the followers of Jesus that
he's talking about the people who were
around Jesus at that time so they've
been elevated in status until the day of
judgment above the disbelievers so who
are the disbelievers is talking about
the
people no no no no so listen put the
words in context what is what is he El
what is he making them Superior in what
are they doing where he helps them and
makes them Superior in remember when
Allah said oh Jesus I will take you and
you up to myself right we we just when
did he do this when when did he make
when did he help the followers of Jesus
when did he do this we just read it when
did he yeah so around about 2,000 years
ago okay so he already did it we we saw
it in' 61 where he actually did it right
we helped those who followed you over
the disbelievers and they became
dominant right we saw it in 6114 right
yeah so what what did he help them in
from those who disbel and elevate your
followers above the disbelievers until
the day of judgment right okay my
brother so essentially read1 614 again
what did he help them do what did he
help them do hold on to their Fe Faith
who were the dis the time the Jew not
hold unto their faith just do me you
know what I'll just I'll just say it
because you like it's it's taking too
long for you to get it they said we will
be helpers of Allah when Jesus asked who
will be my helpers of Allah the
disciples said we will be the helpers of
Allah what does it mean to be help
helpers of Allah spreading his faith
spreading the faith spreading the
message good monism and then it says
that Allah helped them spread the
message right correct so he helped them
spread the message and gave them power
to be dominant over their dis over the
disbelievers who would come against them
spreading the message right elevate your
followers above the disbelievers so
elevate it doesn't say that it'll be
dominant I don't know where you got the
dominant from so where do you get the
word dominant from my brother I'm going
to need you to do help help me help me
out here I need you to help me help you
okay in 60 go back to 6114 did it not
say dominant you read it out for us I
had it on the screen 6114 so this is
this is a different context this is a
different not it's the same context 3
355 is recollecting it's remember when I
said this 6114 we see it in actuality
when he did it 6114 yeah 6114 again all
you who have believed be supporters of
all like oh you who have believed be
supporters of Allah as when Jesus the
son of Mary said to the disciples who
are my supporters of Allah the disciples
said we are supporters of Allah and a
faction of the children of Israel
believed and a faction disbelieved so we
supported those who believed against
their enemy as in those that were
disbelievers and they became dominant
you see it yeah they became dominant
dominant in what over the Israelites
dominant in what though so we supported
those who believed against the enemy and
they became dominant so dominant I would
say in their belief in their IM in the
in in the righteous in the right path my
brother I'm trying not to be rude but
man your your comprehension of your own
scripture is it's it's crazy like your
lack of it seriously like everybody can
get it except the Muslims it's it's
really mindboggling you just said it you
you just said it what are they doing
what are they doing so God is asking so
Jesus is saying who will be my
supporters right for Allah and the
disciples are saying that we will be we
are the supporters of Allah so what are
they doing they are assigning themselves
to Jesus what are they doing supporting
Allah how what does that mean what is
what are they doing so according to the
Islamic version they are practicing or
they preaching monotheism so they're
preaching The Message of Islam is that
correct the gospel the monism monism mon
doesn't say monotheism Jesus came
spreading the gospel and they're going
to help him spread the gospel is that
correct well this is what Islam believes
they are spreading monotheism that's why
no worries so they're spreading the
message is that what they're doing
correct thank you they're spreading the
message so they became dominant in
spreading the message correct of monism
correct okay so they became dominant in
spreading the message so we get to
355 how long were they dominant and
elevated over the disbelievers in
spreading the message how long so
remember when Allah said oh Jesus I will
take you and raise you to myself I will
deliver you from those who disbelieve
and elevate your followers above the
disbelievers until the day of judgment
then to me you'll be all returned so how
long will will their message remain
dominant and elevated over the
disbelievers how long will the message
or how long will the followers be he
said the followers get out of here
there's only there's only so much I can
take so much idiocy I can take from the
Muslims special dishonesty and when you
get caught this is what you have to do
and we see it every single time on my
live streams we see it every time on the
live streams the Muslims getting caught
by their own book and they can't even be
honest with their own text it is that
crazy but we see it every time we see it
every single time he wants us to believe
that the followers of Jesus
the initial followers of Jesus never
believed that he was the son of God they
didn't preach that that that was a later
interpretation disbelievers came in and
infiltrated the belief system and put
this false message that Jesus is the son
of God and that's what became the
dominant message that we know of
Christianity Today well if that's the
case then all failed to keep his promise
because he said that he gave the
followers of Jesus
dominance and superiority in spreading
their message and that their message
will be dominant until the day of
Resurrection so if there's any time
where disbelievers came in and
successfully overcame the message of the
Believers Allah failed and he lied Islam
is false but if we're going to be
consistent with history and we see that
the dominant message has always been
that Jesus is the son of God who died
for our sins rose again on the third day
then those are the actual Believers that
Allah helped so Allah helped them spread
the message that Jesus was the son of
God who died for our sins and rose again
on the third day Islam is false either
way you put it either way you run it
Islam is false either the Christians of
today are the Believers that Allah
helped who preached that Jesus is the
son of God or and in Islam is false
because of that or the Christians of of
today The disbelievers Who overcame the
real Believers and Islam is false cuz
Allah failed to help the actual
Believers like he promised it's Friday
cooking today Friday cook session